In this part of level editing I want to talk about HLOD or hierarchical level of detail generation for our landscape.
Now this option can be found by simply selecting our landscape and then under the HLOD sections in the details panel
we'll find our HLOD texture size policy and HLOD texture size.
Now setting the HLOD texture size policy to specific size allows us to define the size of the resulting texture
that will be generated and applied to our landscape for our level of detail.
And we can see an example of this in our slides in front of us.
At the top we have this set to 256 and at the bottom we have it set to 4096.
So notice that the 4096 one does have more detail in it but one other thing to take into consideration.
This texture is meant to be seen at a very very far distance.
So while 4096 does show some better detail oftentimes this is not going to be needed.
The other thing about generating a texture this large as your landscape grows in complexity and in size
it can take a very long time to generate this texture.
Not to mention a texture of 4096 for your entire landscape is going to take up a lot of disk space as well as memory space.
Let's take a look at how we can quickly do this in the editor.
So first things first if you notice I don't actually have anything to see if I was to come here to my landscape and actually hide it.
I can't actually see my HLOD so in order to see that what we do if we come up here to show
we can come down to HLOD and then show our HLODs and this will allow us right here if we just pop that over like so.
Now what we're going to see here is this is our HLOD asset and if I was to come back here and unhide this this is our landscape.
So let's click on our landscape now that we can see the HLOD results and we're going to come down here to our HLOD section.
You can see here I have again my HLOD texture size policy and my HLOD texture size.
So 128 let's set this to something like 64 and then let's just come up here to build and we're going to build HLODs.
We're going to say build HLODs we're going to go ahead and save this and we'll be right back once this finishes building.
All right now that we are back inside of the editor let's come up here to our landscape.
We're just going to hide this really quick and that is our HLOD result right there.
Now it is got you know it's got some issues right here and there but remember this is
generally going to be somewhere seeing something from like this far away so those little issues might not be that apparent.
However if they are simply just come here to our settings we'll set this back to 128 and come back to build and we will build this.
And you can see it's just going to be that easy to rebuild our HLODs for this landscape.
And with a little movie magic we now have this new version of our landscape.
Let's go ahead and just hide that again real quick.
There we go boom it has been updated you can see it does have a little bit more resolution inside of it.
Things are just a little bit sharper but again remember we're looking at things
off here in the distance so that is a really fantastic result.
Remember again we find this by coming to our landscape.
And then underneath our details panel HLOD and setting our HLOD texture size.